another day another mind-bending episode
of what if just as we recovered from the
emotional torment of the disney plus
series fourth episode longtime mcu fans
were dealt another series of emotional
blows with a speculative episode that
saw many of their favorite avengers
turning on each other this time with
exceptional violence it was awesome
i should be sad but i'm not episode 5 of
the mcu's first animated series
introduced zombies into the marvel
cinematic universe real ones not some
freaky vision reportedly this particular
episode pulled more from marvel comics
than any previous four episodes in a
series that's literally titled what if
head writer ac bradley had a tremendous
amount of creative freedom but for
episode 5 she pulled a good bit of the
blood from the source material so far in
this series we've discovered the answers
to several mysteries what if peggy
carter became a super soldier what if
t'challa was star-lord what if the
avengers never existed what if doctor
strange lost his heart instead of his
hands episode 5's theme is a little
looser with its title being simply what
if zombies
you have finally asked a relevant
question
the story examines what would have
happened if janet van dyne was infected
with a malicious virus while in the
quantum realm which was brought into the
world after hank pym rescued his long
lost love in a flashback an unknowing
hope vandyn brings her infected mother
back through the quantum tunnel and the
virus spreads throughout the entire
pacific northwest within 24 hours the
fallout from this turn of events is
catastrophic and alters the world of the
mcu as we know it
that
[Applause]
oh that sort of seems like overkill
episode 5 of what if picks up the
timeline right at the start of avengers
infinity war after bruce banner has been
beamed to earth by heimdall to warn of
thanos's coming so everything we know
about the mcu before that film is still
canon in this story except for the
reveal that janet van dyne spent her
time in the quantum realm becoming
increasingly zombified from the get-go
we learned that most of our beloved
heroes were overtaken by the virus
before bruce even arrived our survivors
include peter parker bucky barnes bruce
banner and hope van dyne sharon carter
happy hogan and kurt the ex-con worker
from ant-man are also still around and
aiding the resistance against the virus
also floating around is the cloak of
levitation which single-handedly saves
bruce from being devoured by a zombified
dr strange wong iron man ebony moore and
cull obsidian okoye arrives from wakanda
and joins a resistance and we also learn
later in the episode that t'challa and
vision are both still around as well
later on we find out with some horror
that wanda maximoff is a zombie as well
as powerful as she is the silver lining
here is that she has not yet fully
become the scarlet witch so she's not
quite as terrifying as a zombie version
of her could be after the surviving
heroes start to drop like flies and turn
on each other we're left with just peter
bruce kurtz bucky okoye and hope as they
make their way to camp lehigh where a
beacon has been sent out when the team
learns hope will soon zombified due to
an injury she sacrifices herself by
going giant size to help the team cross
a wasteland of zombies to get to the
camp she crashes down in a blaze of
glory as she succumbs to the virus but
not before getting her friends where
they needed to be it's no surprise to
learn here that vision is still around
because he's not made of living flesh
he's of no interest to the zombies he's
also kind of lost his mind we find out
he has been using a kidnapped t'challa
to feed zombie wonder that's no way to
treat your king
one more word and i will feed you to my
children
because vision can't bear to destroy his
love for the greater good he keeps her
imprisoned which is probably not what
wonder would do if the tables were
turned but that's neither here nor there
on top of learning about vision's
desperate scheme to keep wander alive
our heroes also learn that the mind
stone is the key to beating the virus
vision was able to use the stone to keep
an infected scotland alive kind of at
least i know what you're thinking i've
lost weight thank you for noticing to
save the world the team just needs a way
to broadcast the stone's frequency to
all humanity a tall order sure but
doable the only place capable of doing
this as wakanda so the new mission is to
escape camp lehigh with a stone for
africa before they can break through
wakanda the surviving heroes
accidentally release wander and all hell
breaks loose as the heroes start dying
in the fight against her vision also
sacrifices himself by pulling the mind
stone out of his head so surviving team
members can take it to wakanda for
whoever's counting this brings a
synthezoid's mtu death count to four
you'll be fine our final survivors of
the zombie apocalypse are now peter
t'challa and scott who have escaped in a
quad jet to wakanda as the episode ends
we are left to wonder if they will
complete their mission and that seems to
be a big if in the final scene of the
episode a zombified thanos with five out
of the six infinity stones is revealed
to be waiting for them in wakanda and
peter scott and t'challa have no idea
the threat that is coming it looks like
the universe as we know it is going to
crumble yet again what happens if a
quantum virus zombifies all of humanity
well thanos still shows up apparently
i am
inevitable
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one